يقول خبراء أجانب إنه سيكون شتاء قاسيا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بإنفلونزا covid-19
وفيروس يسمى RSV أطفال يعانون من المرض
الأخير وأمراض الجهاز
التنفسي الأخرى يجهدون بعض
المستشفيات الأمريكية كنت أفعل ذلك منذ فترة
طويلة.  لقد كنت في ولاية كونيتيكت
للأطفال لمدة 25 عامًا ولم
أر هذا المستوى من الارتفاع على وجه التحديد من
RSV قادمًا إلى مستشفانا ، والخبر
السار هو أن الغالبية العظمى من الأطفال
الذين يحصلون على هذا لن يحتاجوا إلى
دخول المستشفى لن يمرضوا ،
إليك نظرة على  الأعراض الرئيسية لـ
RSV يمكن أن تكون صعبة بشكل خاص على
الأطفال الذين تقل أعمارهم عن سنة بالنسبة للبالغين ،
فالأنفلونزا هي مصدر قلق أكبر بالنظر إلى ما
رأيناه في أستراليا هذا الصيف ، فمن
المنطقي أن نتوقع أننا سنشهد
موسمًا كبيرًا للإنفلونزا هذا العام.
من المهم حقًا الآن تذكير
الناس بالحصول على لقاحهم بشكل مثالي
قبل نهاية أكتوبر ، الأمر يستغرق حوالي
أسبوعين لبناء تلك الأجسام المضادة
ويقول بعض خبراء الصحة إن
مشتقات متغير Omicron  يمكن أن تتسبب
في زيادة عدوى كوفيد -19 هذا الشتاء ،
لكنها ليست لعبة يبدو أنها
أكثر قابلية للانتقال مع حلول فصل الشتاء
ومع الطقس الأكثر برودة وجفافًا ، يمكنك
توقع بعض الزيادات المفاجئة ، والسؤال الكبير هو إلى أي
مدى قد تكون هذه الزيادة كبيرة.
التقارير